i've just been informed about an air  strike on vinnitsa eight  missiles  an attack against our peaceful vinnitsa  a town that never threatened russia in  any way  a missile strike  brutal and cynical the airport is  completely destroyed they continue  destroying our infrastructure our life  that  our ukrainians had been building up our  grandfathers and grandmothers  you need to close the airspace  the  you need to make a no-fly zone for  russia for all these  terrorists  provide a humanitarian no-fly zone  this is your humanitarian obligation to  protect us to protect people and you can  do it if you don't do it if you don't  provide us at least with the planes that  we could defend ourselves  then we can come to the only possible  conclusion  you want us to be killed slowly